back to las vegas now diamonds are a
girl's best friend well anyone's best
friend and here to help us learn what it
takes to find that perfect diamond is
tracy butchko from max pond luxury tracy
thank you for being here thank you for
having me so we get to talk about
sparkly diamonds my favorite thing in
the world really quickly tell us a
little bit about max pond and what you
guys offer there so we are a luxury
pre-owned pawn shop where we do
collateral loans and we also have luxury
goods that we sell well i've been in a
few times and i can vouch that you guys
have some incredible stuff but i'm
always drawn to the sparkle so let's
talk about diamonds first what makes
kind of the perfect diamond or what
should you keep in mind when you're
shopping for the diamonds so it really
depends on what you're looking for
what's important to you there's the four
c's that everyone's familiar with color
cut clarity and carat weight so it
depends on what's important we can help
direct you i'm gia certified so
if you kind of give me an idea of what
you're looking for we'll help find that
perfect item for you so everything from
say engagement rings i see earrings and
even men's stuff right yeah we have some
luxury timepieces we brought today this
two-tone submariner rolex and this
gorgeous automatic
omega seamaster and let's talk about
these earrings because i'm loving these
especially in front of me here what do
we have what are we looking at here
those are in the design of van cleef and
arpel they are not van cleef
particularly but they have that look
beautiful diamonds well matched in that
clover leaf pattern and i love the way
the light is hitting all of it this far
it's blinding
so let's talk about it when people come
into shop they might be a little bit
overwhelmed so where do you recommend
that they start you know especially when
it comes to jewelry what should the
process be so i usually try to ask a
customer what they're purchasing so is
it a birthday present anniversary
present
engagement ring what are you looking for
and then what does that person already
wear do they wear big pieces do they
like bold items or do they like more
smaller pieces more dainty pieces and
then we can kind of help get them in and
then budget of course but we can get
them into the piece that really fits
what they need i know budget can come
later you can just go ahead and admire
everything what you like first thing you
need
one of each thing and obviously in
addition to jewelry you have the purses
and the shoes but i think this is really
what sets you guys apart and makes you
guys special would you say the same yeah
i hear that all the time from people
that want to go look around pawn shops
right las vegas has a lot
we have the best jewelry that you're
going to find in las vegas and on the
secondary market well i'm loving all the
sparkles and if people out there want to
come visit you guys tell everyone where
you're located where people can find you
we're on the corner of jones and sahara
we're open seven days a week from nine
to six so plenty of time to do some
diamond shopping what do you think how
do these look with my outfit i think i
need that i think i think you need those
for sure i think so too tracy knew i
liked you thank you so much for being
here mercedes i will send it over to you
all right thank you jillian
so